Can you see?
Thái này!
Thái này nó ngà quá hay gì em?
Thái này, muối khách body của nó nó đích...
Thậtieren...
Thậtoon...
Thậtoon cho Hay là...
Thậtoon và váu tr Yin khó...
Cái này, bây giờ, như là cái được nhá nó nó...
Nhầy mà mình sợ một căn, hồi lúc hoàn.
Thậtoon và phòng th基 khói là khẳng ra được...
Thậtoon và phòng ra là cái là...
Châu rồi dễ như thế đó là, ngơ vỡi đâu...
Hải có vệnh chỗ trái này có nước là khủ hвор,
T sao cái chú hả?
S rainy tốt lởi í ch wró lống
L Maker l Rap
Nếu như tìa trời trời trời rất xuống
Tuh mời gặm tâm bình trái hoàn thích không đông
Mình gồm đồng độc ra
Tuy là đồng khô
Cái lẹ l Marin
Thù gạo nên tình mời sống
Mày hết rồi
In anh thông biết, tôi mẹnh cũng mẹan thì sẽ rộn thông